John should independent filmmakers
finance their film with credit cards no
I mean I i usually don't say a blanket
no to anything cuz hey there's a lot of
ways to skin a cat you know well not
that cap should be skin but you know but
I don't think it's a good idea
especially these days to really go into
you sorry oriented debt which is what
credit card debt is at many credit cards
are twenty percent interest and that's
really a burden however I also do feel
that most creative projects need to
start somehow and you know I always
Francis Ford Coppola once said and I
took this to heart that no one else is
going to jump into your project unless
you show your own commitment and putting
your own money in and many artists don't
have their own money outside of credit
cards so you know I think that it's not
terrible for a project to get started in
that way but I would recommend highly
that filmmakers don't get too burdened
with debt so that it really impacts
their lives in a deleterious fashion and
I think now there are so many
possibilities to be creative and engage
audiences that don't involve a lot of
capital that weren't possible 20 years
ago 10 years ago even five years ago
that you know there is it as much of a
need for people to go into credit card
debt to make a piece of work right
footed documentarians pudding I'll say
plane tickets overseas to get the main
you know subject to their film on credit
cards and then going from there and
finding investors but I mean what if
someone doesn't have the audience to go
and crowd fund for it so that's out the
window mm-hmm so you're saying just just
a small portion sort of show that Jeff
some skin in the game but then fine
ultra yeah and I don't want to advise
anyone one way or another
in terms of credit cards you know
because the first thing I'll say is that
it is a problematic way of financing a
project you know because of you know the
absorbing interest that's charged and
it's kind of a hard hole to get out of
so barring mad you know I think at some
points you do have to float certain
aspects of a project you know and credit
cards are certainly one way of doing it
these days you know but I do feel like
you know if you don't have an audience
to crowdfund I think what you need to
start thinking about and this is would
be healthy for your whole project is to
start thinking about how you can create
that audience you know and to you know
spend some time simultaneously engaging
that audience in addition to making the
work and the thing is is that and again
I was just talking to a filmmaker
yesterday you know if there's a if you
have a continuity to your work so that
it makes sense for you to bring your
audience along in your creative process
throughout your career any work that you
invest in audience development now is
going to pay off later so you know you
got to start somewhere and you know the
sooner the better like start with a
small crowd funding campaign you know
amongst whatever network that you have
and then a year later do another one you
know it's like you can't go back to the
well too often but so long as you're
growing as an artist and the project is
developing you know I think there's room
for that you throw out another
hypothetical filmmaker and also the
traditional crowdfund model isn't the
only crowdfund model I mean I think
there's you know if you look at Votto
which is in a sense reverse crowdfunding
you know that's another way to go and
the people who made pioneer one you know
where they made that's a serialized
content and they made an episode and
then people contribute to the further
making of the next episodes I mean
that's another model yeah I guess I'm
just one
how much should you put yourself sort of
at financial peril let's suppose someone
is 50 they have an IRA it's not enough
to retire on but it's a nice little
chunk of change should they take that
step and crack it open and get the
penalties knowing that you know what
this made us surfing I mean my dream
come true that's who's this coming from
I mean that's you know it's hard to say
I mean everything is so individualized
you know I'd happy to sit down and talk
to that person and on the one hand you
don't want to put yourself in financial
peril but on the other hand at some
point you know art is about taking risks
you know and you never know what's going
the world is going to be like and you
know why not at some point you have to
take the plunge but by the same token I
would you know be tempered about making
sure that you really have the ability
that that dream is really going to come
through in some way before you put your
life at risk you know it's interesting I
don't know if you guys follow this guy
Bob Lefferts who writes about music all
the time he has a daily if sometimes
three times a day blog that you can RSS
and he's constantly telling musicians
you know to quit you know because you
don't have enough talent you know yeah
and he's constantly day of an opposite
problem where musicians he's complaining
about an opposite problem where
musicians are only concerned about
developing audience and not making work
whereas filmmakers are more concerned
you know or you know if I complain about
anything that filmmakers are too
obsessed with making work and not enough
about the audience and I think they have
to be obsessed with making the work but
they also have to be concerned about
making audience and he says there's way
too many in the music world who were
just all they want to do is develop
audience and tweet and facebook and blog
and you know but their musics crap so
and he's he constantly tells them get
out of the business you know it's like
too hard you know you're never gonna
succeed so you know
uh I would just say that's a really hard
question to answer
you